so about 18 months ago actually yeah our
son Rio was born through surrogacy and
um so through the the way that all
currently works right now is we had a
whole kind of eight-month period of
waiting until he became legally at our
sun which was quite hard would you would
you agree yeah I the thing is like as a
gay couple we always dreamed of having a
family and the whole surrogacy process
itself went so smoothly
um one of our friends actually had our
baby for us and then the the just the
legal part was a little bit of a
struggle okay so why was it a struggle
what was so it took eight months for him
to be legally yours I think because it's
kind of still new in the UK so with the
different courts I feel like it's not
clear kind of what the rules really are
so I felt like so we ended up having
three hearings and if you can imagine
every hearing you know our son was eight
months into our life he was part of our
family here's our son and we're having
to go to the court to kind of prove that
we can be his parents it was quite a you
know process to go through what sort of
impact did it have on you um I think by
the end the last court hearing we met
you Bears into tears when we actually
got it
um done because I just feel like it was
just such a yeah just such a drain on us
emotionally and we have this account so
we decided to share our journey on Tick
Tock accounts called Stuart and Francis
and we shared this process with our
followers and so many people were blown
away the the laws currently stand as
they do and we just feel with the kind
of updates that are kind of have been
announced today that it's really needed
to kind of move these laws that were
first set in 1980 to kind of move with
the current times and protect both the
surrogate and the intended parents
that's kind of what the laws are in so
what do you want to happen what's the
problem at the moment and what you want
to see happen the thing that I'm really
excited about with the new laws is that
both me and Francis or in the intended
parents will go on the birth certificate
from day one I think that's because also
as a surrogate and the intended parents
neither of these parties want to have
the responsibility of the child like the
the surrogate doesn't want to be left
with a child that she doesn't want and
the intended parents want that
responsibility so I'm really really
excited to see
um which we're hoping that the intended
parents go straight on the birth
certificate I think that would be the
biggest most exciting change for us and
we just feel like it protects everyone
it protects us so who what how do you
protect the surrogos as well by doing
that because the surrogate surrogacy is
the kindest thing anyone could ever do
for anyone and we're just so amazed
we've had two friends that have offered
we've had we're expecting another baby
in August
thank you we've had two friends offered
to be our surrogate which is quite a
unique situation and we just you know
what they're doing for us is incredible
but they decided to become a surrogate
not because they legally want
responsibility of the child when it's
born and the current law you know our
situation because our surrogate is
married even though they have no genetic
connection to the baby her husband was
legally the father at birth as well so I
know it's pretty strange so we're in a
situation in mid last year where our son
was unwell and we took him to hospital
luckily it was only it was covered so it
wasn't something serious but they wanted
to do some further investigations they
want to do a lumber punch on oh bless
him luckily it didn't didn't happen but
this they gave us the forms to sign you
know and we were like we we can't sign
these yeah he's not legally our sons and
she lives three hours away she's in
rectum so what did you have to do well
luckily we didn't do it we didn't do it
you would have had to get Mom yeah then
Mom to come and yeah yeah yeah wow so it
was you know it just we're just you know
we're just so grateful to live in the UK
right now because this is possible
surrogacy is still illegal in Western
countries like Germany Spain so we're
just so grateful that this is possible
we just think the UK is taking this you
know this next step to kind of move it
into the was it any more difficult
because you you're a gay couple or did
that not actually influence no I don't
feel like we had an amazing experience
like even dealing with the hospitals we
were the third surrogsy birth they had
that that year but there was we just
only met with love and acceptance It's
been incredible yeah yeah what's it like
um being um in that position when uh
someone else is carrying your baby for
you that's the hardest part because you
have no control and obviously you know
they all the questions go to her because
she's carrying the baby but it is really
hard and sometimes like right now our
surrogate is pregnant and we don't see
her every day so we can kind of forget
we're pregnant sometimes yeah
um but yeah I think it's the it's the
decisions and for instance you know when
the baby's born if the baby then has to
be kept in overnight the the legal
mother is then the the surrogate so
essentially we could be told by the
hospital you can't stay with your
newborn baby so that's all you can see
in itself is just such an amazing thing
like two families coming together yeah
to create a a live
um and that they are baby is so loved by
so many people it's got such a like a
extended family I just think it's just
such an amazing thing and sometimes it
doesn't necessarily get the Press of how
positive it is positive and experiences
and do you know what you're having in
August we find out soon about 20 weeks
ago
fantastic well do you know what you want
well well happy and healthy is it yeah
thanks for sharing your experience with
this